What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
As we mentiond last week
We have a big surprise for you guys
Surprise
We have just launched our own mobile game!
Infinite Ping Pong
It's a free app
And you can download it on both Apple and Android
The game is made by our friend Johannes Linnama
Who has done the whole development by himself
Go check it out, it's really fun!
The idea of the game
is to get as many shots on table as possible
The opponent will never miss
Move your player by clicking on the screen
And you hit by swiping
The longer your swipe is
the harder your shot is
And the harder you hit, the slower the ball will come back
You can even hit harder by dashing into the shots
One of the coolest features in the game
is the leaderboard
So you can compare your results
to ours and your friends
When you get to a higher level
You can unlock new items, maps, characters and challenges
The game starts here
At the Pongfinity Hall
But as you level up
You get to use the earned coins
to unlock new maps
So you can change the background on which you play
There is obviously three characters that you can unlock in the game:
Me, Miikka and Otto
And it's fun that all of the characters have different stats
So you have to choose which character you play with
And of course
Inspired by our popular Challenge Pongfinity series
There is also tasks and challenges that you can complete in the game
It's a really cool feature that brings another dimension to the game
The game is free to download
and you don't need to buy anything to get higher scores or progress in the game
But there is in-app purchases that will speed up the process
If you decide to buy something in-game
you will be supporting us and our channel
And if you are good enough
There will be a little surprise for you
at score 100
I have never reached that far
I have!
Go and download the game from the links that are in the description
Go and try to beat our hiscores!
Until next time!